garrett cole on the fourth of july
and the boogie down bronx he'll be a 17
start
two of his worst starts have come in
june he's given up five earned runs
three times
and two room runs are less and 13 games
started so the big picture still in play
and
going the distance if he can go seven
inks today but that can have an impact
on the second game so certainly what he
does in this first game is a big deal
garrett cole is ready so is brandon
nimmo
down on strikes and garrett cole has
struck out nimmo to get us started today
so one up one down francisco lindor
coming up
lindor lines one to center staying up
there for gardner
two away the nine home runs he's given
up cole
since they've been checking i wonder if
how many have been on breaking balls
here's dom smith three hits yesterday
after two home runs in the last game in
atlanta and that curveball hit in the
air to deep right field back goes judge
near the wall
and it's out of hand tom
smith with a yankee stadium special
dumps it in the second row
and dom smith red hot now gives the mets
a one nothing lead
and here's pete alonso three two
high-fly ball center field deep going
back
is gardner and he makes the play on the
morning track for the fine lap
lineup is going to face marcus strowman
and on the season this will be a 17
start you know strollman
really kind of wanted to be a yankee
last year at the trade deadline it
didn't happen
he kind of felt disrespected a little
bit so needless to say
you know he's motivated today he's
facing dj lemayo a right hand battered a
lead off lifted out to right field
over in the gap goes nimmo and he'll run
it down on the warning track for the
first down
so now aaron judge who has four career
home runs against strowman
and he grounds one on the left side
right at lindor
and francisco throws him out two away so
strowman has retired the first two luke
voigt the batter
another ground ball for lindor to handle
and a one two three opening inning for
strowman after getting the lead
home second inning in a seven inning
game giancarlo stanton leads off against
marcus strowman
there's a base hit to right center off
the bat
and stanton is the first base runner of
the day for the yankees now georgella
burchella grounds went up the middle in
door
[Applause]
i mean these are the plays that you
really have to take advantage of
if you are the yankees you've got to put
some runs on the board
when you get a huge break like that and
that hits gardner
so the bases are loaded for kyle
strowman is doing everything he possibly
can to help the yankees cross the plate
here this inning
he got higashiyoka up here with an
opportunity and somehow look for
something
up in the strike zone get it out of the
infield at least get on the board
lying to left field that ball is going
to be over the head of mckinney
head up against the wall two-run score
hits
error which cost the mets two outs now
costs them two runs and a chance for
more
lo castro is first at bat as a yankee
left field mckinney makes the catch
tagging is gardner and he will score
it's a safe ride for la castro
and it's 3-1 yanks have the tying runs
on base with dom smith coming up
swinging in the miss cotton
big strikeout for call with the
change-up
so now there are two outs now we'll see
if cole can get alonso
100 miles an hour big-time pitching
and the yankees are in business in the
third first and third and nobody out
so here is state grounded to short
there's one
and there's two one scores yankees lead
four to one no ribby
for stan and now a call and a mess so
for cole
who rarely walks anybody he's walked
three in the game two in this inning and
you got tomas nito coming up
kohl's lost it and needle lines want to
right field that's down for a base in
conforto is in and the mitch get a
little bit closer it's now a four to two
yankee league
nimmo lines one to center field that's
down for a base hit
in the score comes mcneal now it's four
to three yankees
and aaron boone will not let garrett
cole continue
some booze mixed in jonathan lewis
will enter here and the bases are still
loaded
for francisco lindor the door finds the
hole on the right side
base sand mckinney is in neato stops the
third throw back to second
and out at second base is nemo
just an incredible gap for base running
there it's inexplicable
and a big out for the yankees the third
walk in the inning
cole walked a pair and now lewis is
giving up a single and a walk to his
first two hitters and that loads them up
for pete
gonna be a tough play grab by the wizard
the fires the first
oh that was a big league play by the
yankee pitcher
to stop the bleeding the yankees have
the table set first and third and one
out
and that goes over the head of nito and
that allows la mahi to score
five four yankees game on the line it'll
be green against smith
tying run at second base swung on and
popped him up
in shallow right center who's going to
catch it gardner
makes the catch that ends the enemy the
yankees struggling closer or aldous
chapman will try to protect a one-run
lead
this first out is unbelievably huge for
a guy who's been struggling
alonzo leads off in the seventh with the
mets down a run alonzo now was
all for his last 12. the slider hit in
the air to deep left field back toward
the gap at the wall
it's out of there peter lonzo
ties the game with a lead off home run
number 14 for alonso to get the mets
even again it's five to five in the
and chapman has his hands on his head he
cannot believe it he blows another save
chapman has not gotten out he's giving
up a home run a hit by pitch
and now a walk and that's gotta do it as
boom
has to try to win this game chapman's
meltdown continues
right in front of our eyes and lucas
licking will come on the bases are
loaded carrazzo will bat for guillermo
and he drives one down the left field
line back toward the wall
and it's caught by a fan that's going to
be fan interference
the fan clearly reached over the fence
to grab it the mets will have the lead
assuming it's a double and two rbis the
mets will lead
seven to five and all three runs charged
to eralda's chapman
and now nimble winds one in the right
field for a base in
nine to five new york the wheels have
fallen off
here in the brush on the yankee side and
lindor pulls one on the ground that's a
base hit
nemo around third he's heading for the
play 10 to five
and seth lugo will try and get those
last three outs
and that leads the yankees down to their
final out of the afternoon
swinging a liner to first caught by
alonso down to his knees
put it in the books a memorable
subway series win for the new york mets